this is Startalk greetings greetings
greetings welcome to Startalk radio I'm
your host Bill Nye here with wide world
citizen of the world wide world Chuck
nice right and this is a special
all-star edition and Chuck here's the
interesting thing
I am the all-star you are the all I'm
not I'm starring all wise here it's good
now it's really fun I really really
appreciate you guys including me now
this is a cosmic query yes it is yeah I
see you have stacks of query cool
queries yes I do from all over the
interwebs electric thing the kids use -
they're electric machines you're that
thing's catching on oh yeah I don't know
what's cool thank you all for sending in
questions Chuck let's read one let's get
right to it okay and this is from dan
gomez Dan says
what exactly is inside of a vacuum if
not matter then some sort of cosmic
energy the fabric of reality well
there's there's energy passes through a
vacuum right so we love that we're about
light heat all these exciting things
then that you ask you a good question
you know people talk about space-time
using it as one word space-time and it's
generally agreed that not only is the
universe expanding but space itself is
expanding so most of space has what we
reckon is no matter nothing in it so
perhaps the vet any vacuum you have is
also expanding along with space if it's
away from a gravity field or away from a
local gravity field okay maybe it's
expanding and we just can't can't sense
it it's one of the rules it's crazy it's
crazy it's pretty wild it is wild it
really is profound
yeah I'm right actually Dan very good
question them enough to sound so
surprised he's a Star Trek listener our
talk listener which brings me to this
next thing this these questions are
generally about science fiction right
that's right Star Trek let's hopefully
come out our Trek is definitely going to
come up because this is sci-fi and
scientists on TV these are the what what
the increase are about let's go to Sam
th FC hmm all right I was wrong with I
don't know what th FC means but but he's
coming to us from twitter twitter
twitter i just made up a whole new
social media look for it
twitter coming to a jackknifed near year
sweater sweeter so give us a tweet from
the twit here's what he says
what pixels you wish that didn't sound
right I apologize it was a tweet from
the Twitter what pixel scientists do you
think would if he or her and his or her
science were real would benefit mankind
the most do you have somebody that you
like as a fictional scientist that you
believe if they were real they would
actually be a huge benefit to mankind
the person the man or woman who invents
a way to filter salt water and make it
into fresh water Wow and that person may
exist right now but this is a
hypothetical thing Wow it may not be one
person maybe a corporation who
continually drinks around with materials
to make this possible but that would be
great if you could make sea water
economically into fresh water so now
what is a big deal of not big deal
what's the difficulty
obstacle for capturing fresh water from
salt water a desalinated energy it takes
energy right so must you either have to
boil it and often in a partial vacuum so
called partial flash distillation or you
push it through a osmotic filter and
filter the filters right molecules and
get the fresh water to come on the other
side but it takes a lot of pressure
that's what they do on cruise ships and
submarines oh really yeah so one can
help but wonder if there isn't some
trick to make that easier right one is
hopeful and is it is it going to be
necessary one day I mean are we going to
be in a position where we're out of
fresh water
well yeah people talk about all the time
but it would enable so much it just it
would be so cool if you could take
seawater and make it into fresh water
along the coast most people in the world
live along Coco's so it would be a
really a terrific thing if you could do
it economically especially for the
developing world nice I love it so you
mean what's funny is that they were
talking about a character but you went
with an actual scientific thing at some
human simile that can actually do at
some point no love heping right now
while we're talking star wise there may
be somebody out there doing it as we
speak
all right here we go wow this person
nope they dumped yourself it's Kelly
Clemente Oh Kelly Kelly Kelly Clemente
Oh wants to know this Doc Brown and the
DeLorean stock grown
the good the bad and what do you think a
flux capacitor really is so it could be
let's start with the following thing we
just did for those who watched our talk
on the TV we just did a time travel bit
where I was in one of the DeLoreans
that's used it was used in the movie
there's a car in New Jersey that
maintains these movie Cars Batmobiles
and Green Hornet cars right and the door
so I was in it and I threw a switch and
it was funny and charming so the flux
capacitor you may recall is running on
banana peels and stuff right and then as
far as we know you can't travel through
time but science fiction writers love
that yes and can you go back and tie the
big questions can you go back in time
and change history
what'd you just get the mechanical
things hi tannic to slow down man I
gee-whiz see the thing is he would slow
down and somehow the Titanic would still
sink that's it if your interpretation of
time travel but you know on what is
generally regarded as the very best of
the original Star Trek series city on
the edge of forever
mmm-hmm go back in time and somehow
Hitler takes over the world because the
passivism from Edith Keeler keeps the
United States from entering the wars
because Kurt actually saves her from
getting hit by a car
you're familiar and they had changed and
then that to end maybe of everything
more modern viewers young people may
wonder if you can send an emissary back
in time to have sex with a waitress who
then turns out to be your own mother
right can you do that the way they did
in that determinate er that's that's the
appellate office Eliminator but
traveling in time is quite difficult
unless like Chuck and myself you are
happy with traveling just one way right
forward older I closer to death
yeah and that's where we're going right
now
I started off laughing I'm I end up
crying artist is an artist and it is a
sibling thing after you reach adult head
your salt hood Heaven's bill yes if you
reach adulthood your head
is headed toward death yes very
troubling but nevertheless apparently
true fact as opposed to a false back now
this question took a decidedly morbid
turn well or either that or deal okay
we're only going one way you can't go
back in time so play the hand you're
dealt
alright yeah well with it quit pining
for something that's not possible yes
you're never going back to win that big
game at state okay that is a learning
experience for your next big game and
then also furthermore to continue there
is a very that which I say for comedic
effect there's a very reasonable theory
in physics that you could build a time
machine but you could only go back to
when the machine was built couldn't go
any further
no and furthermore further back in time
more you can only you have to travel at
relativistic speeds to get there which
would be akin to falling into a black
hole which would tear you apart from its
own gravity so it's just not that easy
odd so everybody I don't mean to be
dismissive of time travel but don't
count on it to solve your problems let's
say you live on a planet that is where
certain species is burning so much
ancient fuel that they're accelerating
the rate of warming by about a factor of
a million let's just say it
you can't pine gimme the day what kind
of planet you can't pine for the day
when you could have done something about
it the turn of a couple centuries ago
you got to play the hand were dealt
right now and address climate change
right right which you know I'd like to
believe it's going to happen yes but I
also believe that people are stupid
and none of you listening no yeah you oh
no other in our voices right now little
people there are other people who are
quite frankly stupid and they don't
believe anything you just said as a
matter of fact why don't
is a senator his name is Inhofe and he
actually wrote a book called the biggest
hoax ever or something like your your
digressing a bit Chuck but I appreciate
it he's a senator bill I know
the gods he gets reelected all the time
represents there's only two of them for
a state
I know ever since half of a state ID Oh
any sudden folks guys like you who do
this so they can get money to do because
that's what happens when you say that
this just you're going kind of Bill
Cosby on me there's a pattern I would
like to invite you over for a cappuccino
bill thank you doctor all right that's
said yes Jacques your digression is
worthy it's just something to think
about you know we time travel is a cool
idea in science fiction but let's keep
our eye on the prize we almost certainly
cannot travel through time we cannot go
back in time and fix things right so we
got to play the hand were dealt they
beat on there you go let's move on to
another query and and keep those very
grave words in mind
oh they're also empowering they're also
impound yard empowering constraints are
empowering absolutely gotta solve this
problem let's go okay here we go
Jonathan be east at Beckham East listen
I like that from Twitter says if you
could interview any fictional scientists
fictional scientist sectional scientist
somebody from the movies or a book or
anything like that who would it be and
why and he's coming to us from Indiana
this was fictional fictional so I'm like
is there any fictional character that
you Meyer whatever they embody the care
during bodies certain value first cut as
you'd say mr. Spock right you would you
like to chat it up with mr. Spock I have
to tell you that I've often fantasized
about uh but then fictional scientist a
guy who invents the time machine in the
HT Welles The Time Machine right that
might be an how did you do that yeah
that's a pretty yeah especially how did
you do it out of bubblegum and a
pinwheel or whatever yeah that's it was
at the oil man on it the oil something
you disable to try that would be a good
thankful questions right but I will say
as charming is all it is there's some
real people I'd love to know I was about
to go there yeah yeah I mean I was about
to say yeah II wouldn't like to talk to
what would you now that would you rather
speak to rosalind Franklin or Franklin
or an Albert Einstein oh man yeah buddy
I'd like to talk to Rosalind so yes you
don't hear that much about her okay
people write books now but I would like
to know what her life was like sweet so
she had to play she had a tough road hoe
there she was the only woman on the bang
I was going to say when you're a female
I mean back in the nineteen fifty it's
not going to because you were down not
hip not down she took the picture that
enabled Watson and Crick to envision DNA
right the spiral the double helix but
did she all envision it first hmm
because she looked at the picture and
then the men took credit right arguments
have ensued ha
there have been the whole radio shows
devoted to this argument I can't resolve
it right now but it is intriguing and
clearly still have them ramifications to
this day we are probably one of the most
important discoveries ever yeah by the
late Darwin and Russell discovered
evolution without any knowledge of DNA
it's amazing it is amazing it is amazing
yes talk about discipline scientific
methods just like all straight
observations Irving and thinking exactly
we don't forget if you ever read Origin
of Species Darwin did all kinds of very
diligent naturalist experiments it's
really impressive guy I mean I know
everybody says that but he really was
quite the experimentalist as well as the
observing
no list naturalist right all right cool
lead on so there you go there you go
there you go good good question I like
that all right let me move on to another
query
this is Denard springle coming to he I
like that name coming to us from Google+
he says how much more interesting would
lost in space have been if they'd
elaborated more on dr. Maureen
Robinson's biochemical background
instead of having her be the typical
housewife in space preparing meals
tending to the Godin etc etc well it
sounds like from your point of view
mister miss Pringle would not better
and notice that compare and contrast the
contemporary show lost in space with
Star Trek right Star Trek the woman
women we're in part yes there was a lot
of legs yes there are a lot of any
scares a lot of nice uniforms mmm but
ultimately being women green women of
who were strangely hot yes but
ultimately right there in the middle of
the whole thing was lieutenant Uhura yes
it was an empowered woman if you ran
things and then you'd require to come
across your woman Romulan who was in
charge of a ship and so on right and so
then you go forward into the Star Trek
series you have salt I'm sorry go bring
no Chuck take it of course there's
Captain Janeway right there running the
whole freakin star starship who became
Admiral Janeway that's right and notice
but that shows that like the woman's
movement at least here in United States
was reflected in science fiction right
you know what I mean that you know what
I mean so if there I can't hear you I
know why I would say such thing but you
see that the evolution right there and
by the way Nichelle Nichols came to the
35th anniversary of the Planetary
Society October 2015 and she told the
story again Chuck she's told the story
countless times she's very gracious
about it that what Martin Luther King
called her yes gnarlie on the phone I
have a dream yeah and he said you can't
quit this job she was going to quit she
wanted to go back to Broadway or
whatever she was as a big
I'm actress not pretending to be in the
23rd century and he said she can't quit
this job
he saw the value yeah and her being on
the bridge of a starship in the future
and being as a ranking officer and
Tenant who was responsible for all kinds
of important things right and so it was
a really a moving moment for me is just
a few months ago Wow you know what's
funny about lieutenant hora is a lot of
people said well she was a Sue's number
two operator you know she was and the
truth of the matter was she was the
first contact for anyone but he was
Capcom that's right but really that
comes a big job it goes so she was a big
deal and she made decisions and she had
to remain calm in some pretty stressful
situations albeit fictional ones but it
was to the point where Martin Luther
King himself says my friend MS Nichols
you can't quit this gig because you're a
role model for african-american people
and women especially I do believe you
are future it was really and I make
salmon a story that she told I gotta say
I was completely unaware of that story
and that's a great but she's told a lot
of times which is very nice about it
not a very cool that's very cool then it
kind of goes to show you the importance
of television revision science science
fiction and by the way the thing about
Star Trek as a Trekkie
yes it's an optimistic view of the
future through science it is not an
apocalyptic view of the future it is not
science as bad and leads to disaster its
science is good and leaves to all
material needs being taken care of and
any conflict we have is when we
encounter new cultures who are not
totally hip to right they don't get it
the way we do all they haven't had a
chance yeah there you go all right it's
super cool all right here we go this is
a core 8 kilobits oh heavens Chuck you
gotta edit before you read only got 30
seconds left in this edit you're
coughing to death Oh
Merson sent you a joking I thought I got
you right in number one it was with the
joke Mary and I get to this cosmic
queries with a science fiction bent
we go how far are we so let's get the
question we'll tease it come back after
the break brilliant what's the question
is the question how far are we from
force fields and inertial dampers that's
the question from coreg kilobits Kate
we're not too far from either one and
Chuck and I will tell you all about it
when Startalk returns right after this
welcome back I that's I'm your host Bill
Nye welcome back to star chakra that's
my colleague the wide world short nice
who is rendering his own acapella
version of the original Star Trek theme
song and the reason he's doing that
because this cosmic query segment is a
generally on a science-fiction theme yes
it is now we had a query about force
fields yes we did it was from a dildo
but I racial damping and when the core
rate kilobits who said on Instagram how
far are we from force fields and
inertial dampers so let me just say in
the in the biggest picture you live in a
force field gravity is a force field it
can be thought of as a field and
recently it was proven that it also
apparently travels in waves gravity does
and so this was predicted or very
reasonable to physicists and now we had
an instrument that measured that but I
think I know what at which you drive
well plus we also have dampers inertial
dampers the OL of the British term was
dampener but in American English the
middle syllable got dropped and this is
a shock absorber in a car and it a
damper generally means something that
goes at the rate the faster you move the
car axle the more damping you get the
more damping restart retarding force you
get right it's a little bit out of your
mathematical experience for most people
but it's out of your every that is out
of your everyday experience and you know
this when you when you try to bounce a
car up and down which you can do you can
make that with the cars in park
everybody perfectly safe push it up and
down you'll find the faster you try to
make it go the more dip
now with that said just put your switch
on your lowrider that's all oh yeah with
you for our lowrider listeners the many
Startalk lowrider listeners that are out
there I'm sure there are a few of you
thank you for your good work right now
but I think what she's driving at is
tractor beam no it in fact I heard a a
pundit I believe on Meet the Press use
the term tractor beam talking about the
current presidential election yeah a
tractor beam is so far not a real thing
of course wouldn't it be great instead
of a tugboat having to throw a line out
to the barge it's towing it could just
do it with some sort of electromagnetic
beam with with the company sound effect
that would bring the barge up the river
or through deep space easily so it's a
cool idea I don't know I think we're
pretty far away from that okay don't
think we're pretty far away pretty far
away
you have forcefield we do have force
field or living in one you may rub your
hair on a balloon and feel your hair
stand on in on your forearm and then you
also wouldn't get a beam of light that
pushes the spacecraft through space ah I
wonder if I'm planetary suicide for
example hmm sounds vaguely familiar to
me planetary gorg consider joining yes
oh you were saying Knight say leave me
another query novel idea light sailing
no it's cool it was really good and
we're going to fly again this was
scheduled for September but it will
probably ship ship slip to November huh
be a ride on the Falcon heavy
Oh SpaceX rocket with 27 engines instead
of 9 I cool alright man
well good luck good luck for the next
flight here we go Walter Vinci he wants
to know this in sci-fi if one were to
have a laser gun capable of producing a
visible shot
what would the effects on the shooter
the target and those in the vicinity be
so he's basically talking about a phaser
or there are laser weapons
okay we had a laser weapon flying around
on a 747 and the idea is the momentum
which you're talking like the recoil
from a conventional bullet type gun
shotgun whatever is very small with a
laser because all you're doing is
reacting the photon pressure but what
the deal is is you're sending heat at
the target and so the heat can damage a
target in a new way that's not momentum
it's not recoil it's burning stuff
fighting stuff up and then if you tuned
it you can have a maser a microwave beam
that messes up the enemy's radar right
that's uh not that anybody would spend
tax dollars doing that in our oh sure
now this whole way of life but I've
heard of it
and would it make the killed sound I
mean what I hope so we ever make a way
how we produce that pure sound oh they
got a guy wire you know what I mean a
real long wire that holds up an antenna
right and capped it okay and that's the
going in it's so it's conventional
mechanical resonance just like a violin
or guitar string exactly it has a
certain tightness very cool nice all
right we all know that's the sound of
blaster it's a blaster gotta say saw the
new Star Wars movie speaking of people
yeah that the the stormtrooper armor yes
it's not very good and what is it
do people burn right through it well
yeah I you know I don't know why they uh
you would think we somewhat protective
but every stormtrooper that gets hit by
a blaster goes down and goes down pretty
easily yeah yeah it's bad yeah all right
here we go
it's another fiction problem that I
can't really no one I wasn't consulted
okay do you think okay this is from a u
tku au TKD mm-hmm
do you think something such as the death
of the planet Krypton could ever happen
to earth no right any other questions
you just exploding planets don't this
isn't it doesn't happen with that said
the Earth's moon
oona parently was created by a pretty
big thing hitting the proto-earth
the earth in its early days this wasn't
fully formed the way it is right now so
we did destroy a planet but maybe it
formed a new planet and a moon but
that's not the same as the way it's
depicted in super members such as blows
up yes it just proposed and that's it
and completely falls apart yeah so I
don't see any way for that to happen
stars ah they do that well duper Nova
they do both right Novik blow up and
they implode right yeah they do all that
but this is returned by the planet and
so if you like to worry about things I
wouldn't put that up high right I'd put
climate change way apart Leah pardon and
then Ben Krypton like that yes yes yes
okay gotcha so I don't need to put any
kids inside up a little escape pod or
probably not you know send them up to
much better Alec remove together the the
environment we have much better
so make an inclusive pod there you go so
I guess it had been Clouseau pod rather
than in pardon me stay on earth pod yeah
which is called Earth yes oh we should
probably take care of this place should
here we go uh yes this is Scott that's
his title that's pretty good yes this is
Scott yes this is Scott what's your
query
that's what yes this is got ones too no
thoughts in our country's education
system particularly as it pertains to
scientific ignorance of the average u.s.
citizen could I have some of that from
you mr. Nye
well we gotta be concerned so for
example I was at the science teacher
convention okay and one of the fights
that the science teachers association
fights is this current opposition to
common core standards yes I hear that's
a big big deal now in floor you wouldn't
think it would be why not have a set of
ideas that we agree everybody should
know everybody should learn the alphabet
right for example right it'd be hard to
read and conduct your life without
memorizing the order of the letters sana
yeah yeah so
along that line there are some other
things we want people to know about
certain plays in certain poems and
certain pieces of art right we also want
people to know certain facts and
discoveries in the process of science
and the process of science but right now
also the educators around the u.s. got
together and came up with this Common
Core of standards right Co re of
standards but then it came to be opposed
by certain states who don't want to
teach evolution ah well ok now see this
is being this common core's being
opposed in the name of states rights ok
but it's being opposed really by people
who are not aware of the fundamental
idea in all biology see I have to tell
you that they're quite insidious the way
they make their argument because they
never let you know that there's an
actual opposition to something so
specific as evolution it states right
states what they never broached the
issue of evolution in the fight for
common core and I've all went to fight
against common core and I've always
wondered why is it that it's just you
know one particular group of people who
are always decrying common core and then
I thought first everybody thought it was
a great idea of conservatives and
progressives but then when people
realized that if you had science
teachers including the basic idea in all
of life science the evolution they
started to like totally break and so
there's a basic idea and geology plate
tectonics right right there's a basic
idea in physics energy can neither be
created and destroyed ok and so we love
that so there's a basic idea in live
science that things change as they
reproduce which we call 'evil the
process of evolution dilution right my
goodness people Wow I you know what I
this is why I love co-hosting these
shows because certain things just pop up
on these shows oh yeah never realize
little business it's is it matters why
we answer these queries
exactly and this is super cool because
that's the real deal the real deal is
its evolution
they don't want problem is evolutions
they're afraid of it there's some people
who are in power
Neil Bryson myself you I presume yes are
excited and empowered by the idea that
we don't have all the answers
exactly other people are deeply troubled
never honest all the answers everything
spelled out right now we want to know
everything there is to know about the
universe right now and when you
challenge that they get they get
unsettled yeah that's I consider that
entirely my fault educated I'm getting
people excited about it they screw up
afraid of don't blame yourself
no that's Wow so there you have it hey
listen this is yes this is Scott thank
you for that question that was uh that
was that's like lightning it's really
good yeah all right let's move on uh
let's get to spend forty six spinning
spammy spending wants to know this in
order to achieve warp speed oh yeah like
in Star Trek well you do you know the
way you do in Star Trek right you know
erlan number one engage that's how you
achieve it by the way Spenny number one
engage
what would the ship have to be made out
of so well it's generally agreed that
you'd start with some sort of
unobtainium
and build out from there keep in mind
there is no evidence that you can
actually travel at warp speed it's a
science fiction device to enable
interactions between people you know
what makes any good story is what's
happening between people yes there can
be Andorians and Romulans and Klingons
there can be Zeno nians and so on but
there really any science fiction story
has to do with us Clemens interacting
right and yeah there's some issues about
what's possible technologically in the
future or the past but it's really about
what people are doing to each other so
there's no there's no evidence that
there really is a warp drive and I don't
know what the ship would be made of yeah
okay they are really strong it would
because you're warping space to travel
through it which means whatever it is is
getting stretched out through space sure
they're showing up someplace has
artificial gravity everybody speaks
English when you get there that's key
hahaha time so that's awesome yes how
did that happen here we are
halfway across the galaxy but yet
somehow these guys speak English it's
crazy I'm an unexpected you know it's a
remarkable example of Hodgkin laws of
parallel planetary development why I am
I'm an old geek I love it take it take
it of it here we go here we go oh my god
mmm
here we go from Ethan Bottoms Ethan says
bill what's your favorite sci-fi
technology and what would be its
real-life equivalent to things Sting's
first of all I'd love to have a
transporter Godzilla but people have
done analysis on the information theory
involved in taking a few trillion cells
and putting them back together
reassembling them the huge amount of
energy required but the other one that
we'd all like is subspace radio right
where no matter where the other person
is matter how fast he or she is
traveling matter what's going on you can
talk to him or her yes we've almost got
it
for real I mean you had to take out your
mobile phone you can talk to pretty much
anybody in the world once in a while so
the transmission is not as good as it
might be once in a while it's breaking
up once all you have to move near the
window right a small time zone going in
my own apartment no reason yes your data
costs more than your voice and so on but
we're getting close where you can talk
to anybody anywhere anytime now you can
fly on planes six miles above the earth
yes and be on the Internet communicating
taking care of things it's not going to
be long before people will be able to
talk routinely I'm sure there'll be
phone booths on planes again now if you
remember the radio phones that were ten
bucks a minute or something
no airplane ah but this this will come
back around we'll have the equivalent of
subspace radio right okay so so space
radio and that's what I'd like be nice
now be nice like you chuck mm-hm n I
like that I like what we did there it's
brilliant it's very cool no one's ever
thought of it all right here we go nigh
the end of this segment we are not the
end of the segment I don't even think
well you know what I'm going to go ahead
and give you this one uh
why are fit this is a Hova Casanova
why are fictional scientists usually
portrayed as bad guys as you need
enemies and stories and you want the
good guy to be like you gotyou man
against the universe man against himself
or man against man that's how you run an
English class so you have the man be a
bad guy from the futures fictional this
is Startalk with Chuck nice and I've
been your host Bill Nye turn it up loud
and keep looking up
welcome back to star talk radio I'm your
host Bill Nye here with the worldwide
citizen of the wide world Chuck nice
right yeah and it's the cosmic queries
continued where we take your questions
from the cosmos and your enquiries and
do our best to respond Chuck well you
are going to do your best verse but you
have a light we're here for me rock you
provide great insight on the show Oh
bill that's very nice of you to say you
are beyond kind sir ah here at Kayle
Kayle
who else could sell you say Kaylie
except you use I do
wells good butcher the name yeah take it
better than you chuck here we go Kaylie
Bush wants to know this in many science
fiction movies hypersleep is used by a
striper asleep hypersleep is like
astronauts on long voyages to make their
trip seem shorter is hypersleep possible
if so would it be a valid method to keep
future astronaut sane during long trips
in space a couple things about that
we you may have met a bear for squirrels
these kids hibernate a good little
something called hibernation yeah and so
it's very reasonable they're mammals
mere mammals is very reasonable that you
could figure out how they do it
right and then you would enable
astronauts do that it's not I don't
think it's to entertain to keep
astronauts from going crazy so much as
to keep astronauts from aging to match
right you go on these long trips and
then it seems reasonable to do that
however with that said Mark Kelly yes
just finished almost a year in space 340
days in space and he remarked you know
you can go two years I could go two
years astronauts are anything but bored
right they have if anything too much to
do that's what he said things going one
of the things he said is that there's so
much to do there's so many things all
day long that he's doing that he doesn't
think about it like yeah like that he
doesn't he doesn't run out of mental
stuff to do so this is a great question
but very reasonable to enable astronauts
to make this long journey without having
to eat as much right
and process the waste as much and having
as much time seriously in sleep cycles
very reasonable to have people in
suspended animation and in science
fiction movies what you generally do is
have the people in suspended animation
kill each other or die yeah or wait one
of the chambers malfunctions right and
when they get wherever they're going
it's a corpse yeah yeah dry it up quick
yeah and he didn't even know it or she
because they were he or she was asleep
during this traumatic time but this is
it's a fine idea in science fiction but
it goes way back because we observed
bears hibernate why couldn't we do that
with the right hormones or berry and
bark diet yes it's a good question there
you go good question oh wait way to go
Kaylee eating the cool guys Smith
that's quite a claims what a clean as he
says why does it seem that with every
new generation there is a new level of
both scientific acceptance and
scientific ignorance which is a
wonderful question especially when
you're thinking about science fiction
I mean he's absolutely right when you
think back from the time of Galileo till
now Jesus man dead leaps and bounds
we've made but yet when you look at
where we are right now you can't believe
the people are such idiots that they
believe some of the things I believe for
example that's an example like for
example that human activity may be
creating a climate change that is Dilla
Terius to the entire ecosystem of this
planet upon which we live and denying
that and denying that that's what in the
face of evidence or denying that
organisms change to the process of
evolution how about that yes so though
we have clear clear evidence fundamental
idea in life sign so you're asking a
great question I think people there's an
expression I think in almost every
culture the good old days good old days
people have a way we I think it's a
survival mechanism we have a way of
suppressing the really traumatic times
that's embracing the happy times right
and these are the good old days and so
the ultimate manifestation of that is if
only things were the way they were when
I understood everything how it gets away
from me as these changes around us are
happening in technology culture the
speed of things but you got to get over
and it's back to this deal that I talk
about all the time
some people are greatly troubled by
change yes other people accept it as
part of the excitement of being alive
right so it's a great question but we
are working very hard here to Startalk
to empower the world citizens to know
science mm-hmm and unplanned choice
decided to know the cosmos in our place
within it that's why we want to know the
cosmos and realize that we don't know
everything and pursue truth in nature to
find out nature's rules so that we know
where we fit in in the great scheme of
things here did we come from are we
alone these are deep questions answers
with science some people think it's cool
other people are troubled and the
troubled people are the ones living in
the past they have learned so far
hey I have to say that that was a very
cool question eaten cool guy Smith thank
you Ethan Smith the core guy it on here
we go
BTU Oh 105 British thermal unit Oh 105
105 wants to know this the professor on
Gilligan's Island always seem to be
using seawater and coconuts to power
gadgets like radios first of all is that
feasible depends if you have enough
dissimilar metals but the classics you
might be familiar with her copper and
zinc and you can make a battery but I
don't know that you can power a coconut
Mattie oh man I was going to say I
remind you a lot of the common good
habits were aesthetic if it's a tropical
island yeah exactly I remind you a lot
of the stuff the professor did on
Gilligan's Island was not real and so
this enabled the enable the plot to be
advanced and you'll notice generally in
Gilligan's Island you'd get it almost
working yes
for a few seconds seconds and then ah
doggone it and so with that said
changing the subject to a more recent
more desperate situation on lost ah what
I say as a I was a pretty good boy scout
right get off the island exactly what
you people because all they cared about
was what was happening on the island I
just got to say I watch them was at the
Blair Witch Project yes get out of the
woods what's wrong with you
we lost the map would follow the stream
you clowns there you go I had no
sympathy for those people maybe somebody
will kill them then we can move on yes
Oh bill bill you're so harsh I'm just
telling you these are through the
process of science you would find a way
you would find a way to get off the out
of the woods and off the island that
especially how long was that on five
years yes three and a half years yeah
somebody would get something done people
all right there you have it
BTU the professor was a fraud not a
sensational character fictional
character
I think he never had anything that
worked because he was secretly doing
something with ginger so I don't need to
know Chuck yeah but are you ginger or
Mary Ann uh you know I got to tell the
truth I'm more of a Mary Ann I'm told
Mary Ann I'm a Mary Ann guy yeah I'm
sympathetic to the gingers I'm
sympathetic to the gingers but you know
that was a little dead looked a little
high-maintenance and did that'll work
honestly a lot of work on in there yeah
and and and didn't you know didn't look
like it would be worth it whereas Mary
Ann said she's accessible and also felt
like when it you know when when my
pursuits were achieved that I may want
to spend some time with Mary Ann uh yeah
so everybody if you're not familiar with
these references a lot of the reason
young men watch television is to look at
women and if you look at the cover of
any net I walk by here in New York you
walk by newsstands continuing all the
time so many of the magazines feature
women rather on the cover not no problem
with that I got to say if it ain't broke
so on this show
Gilligan's Island we can all ask
ourselves which of these contrasting
personalities would you prefer right I
think this is a good moment Chuck with
that important digression resolved yes
get at last to the lightning round
ah yes and that is where we will speed
things up and take as many questions as
we can in the remaining time so let us
move on and say from who um
Seba films wants to know this hi Bill
are you happy I am happy because you're
a mural and sending questions or queries
to Startalk
there you go that was simple enough
we're off to a very good start this is
from Andres gamma oh seven Andres gamma
oh seven wants to know this in Star Trek
are you really when you're teleported to
another place are you really being
teleported or is it a copy of you oh no
you're really being teleported right
I've seen it easy enough
Jay Shipka wants to know this is it is
it possible to convert sound waves into
an energy source energy source has to be
really loud think about how little
energy it takes to make a big symbol
crush I mean really compared to
something else you know if you have
stereo speakers they might be a hundred
watts
I see how loud that gets so yeah we turn
electrical energy into sound all the
time
Wow there you go doing it right now it's
a radio podcast yes there's your answer
Jay Shipka happening right before your
silk'n he wants to go the other way you
want to take a what makes economic boom
moderation okay here we go to do
something alphabetized wants to know
this what are the chances of Humanity
recovering after a catastrophic
extinction event the subject of many
many movies they're pretty good humans
are said to be extinction proof that is
to say there's so many us living on so
many continents that even in a
go ahead remnant somebody will be around
and they'll be doing it they'll be
making more humans I'm just if you like
to worry about things that when I'd set
that one aside okay there you go
Benjamin and Luria Benjamin and Lauria
and he wants to know this could Rick's
portal gun from Rick and Morty ever
exist in other words could we ever have
a means of creating a dimensional portal
oh yeah she's enough No
you think you feel better now but it
should it's that it enables the plot
okay DJ pure logic wants to know this
will humanity survive long enough to
achieve a type 2 or 3 civilization we'll
see won't we if we can live on pure
energy and become electro bores it's not
going to happen this weekend right
climate change is going to be a problem
before then these are great questions
maybe something worth achieving but bear
in mind the type 1 2 & 3 civilizations
are human constructs who knows if there
are any of them and what they think of
us very nice Chris show a drum last name
show a drum solo drum solo drum Chris
children wants to know this what did you
learn today bill I learned how Chuck
feels about climate change that's earned
he's got three kids yeah I have to tell
you I just got I'm not going to get back
on my little thing here because yeah I'm
very concerned um atom bomb baby wants
to know this if you can show one thing
be it a photograph a painting or a piece
of music a book or a movie or something
completely different to an intelligent
species from somewhere outside of our
solar system what would it be and why
that's a great question is a great
question if it's one thing one thing
that you could show them with it would
it be art would it be literature would
it be a photograph would it be you know
a mathematical equation uh I might show
them a rocket I might show them a
spacecraft okay but
that's a tough one it's a tough one
mm-hmm think I might I might show them I
would just give them the Internet and
say have at it have at it one thing one
thing it's the Internet here you go all
right so this is a Davy Jones from San
Bernadino California wants to know
what's your opinion on how science is
overall depicted in Futurama and
Professor Farnsworth a great scientist
or the greatest scientist on TV it's
just it's just fun you guys
just fun don't put don't put too much
voracious uh true facts there aren't
that many facts in Futurama with that
said Chuck we've come to the end of our
show
having cosmic queries on Startalk it's
have been my worldwide citizen of the
world Chuck nice yes and I've been your
host Bill Nye please keep looking up
this is Startalk
[Music]